This is the belief, the position of all
the historic apostolic churches, Coptic,
Church of the East, Catholic, and
Orthodox that Peter was given primacy of
position. He was singled out to be the
head of the apostles and given authority
over them, but an authority that he
exercised in humble service, not lording
it over them. And you see evidence of
that in the New Testament in that Peter
is often singled out for privileges not
given to others. For example, on the
Mount of Transfiguration,
out of the 12 apostles, only three were
chosen to see it. One of whom was Peter.
Right.
>> When Gyrus's daughter was raised, only
three were allowed to see the miracle.
One of whom was Peter. Right.
Mhm.
>> When Jesus prayed in the garden of
Gethsemane, only three were allowed to
be near Jesus to hear his actual prayer.
The others were at a great distance. One
of whom was Peter. Correct.
>> Yes.
>> And Jesus singled out Peter for a
resurrection appearance. He appeared to
Peter individually. If you go to 1
Corinthians 15, open up 1 Corinthians
chapter 15, read five for me.
>> And that he was seen by Cphus.
>> Notice the name Cphus again, right?
calls him Cphus.
>> Y
>> So here you have Jesus appearing to
Peter singularly an individual
appearance to Peter then to the 12 then
to the 500 then also to James and then
Paul. So you see Peter is being set
apart for special privileges not given
to the other apostles. Even privileges
not given to James and John. And another
privilege you'll see that the Lord gives
to Peter. If you go to Luke 22:31-32,
>> the Lord said, "Simon, Simon, indeed
Satan has asked for you that he may sift
you as wheat, but I have prayed for you
that your faith should not fail. And
when you have returned to me, strengthen
your brethren."
>> Now, in your translation, you don't see
the difference in the pronoun you. So,
I'm going to give you
I'm going to give you the King James
real quickly, and it's in the Greek. You
don't need to know Greek. I'm not a
Greek scholar, but just saying. Okay?
Did you notice the first thing Jesus
singles out Simon again, right?
>> Yeah.
>> He doesn't address every one of them,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, so first thing I want you to
notice from this verse, he speaks to
Peter specifically and individually. He
doesn't say to everyone. The second
thing he does for Peter, he says, I
prayed for you. You don't see it in your
translation. You is singular, meaning I
prayed specifically for you. That's the
second thing. The third thing, you know,
Jesus entrusted Peter with the
responsibility of restoring the rest of
the apostles. So notice the three facts
you see from this passage. And I'm going
to give you the authorized version
because in the authorized version, it
does something for you where you can
know whether the pronoun you means one
or two or more that you don't find in
modern versions unless they add some
further clarification. And the Lord
said, Simon, Simon, behold, Satan has
desired to have you. Now if you notice
you, it's y. That's common sense. But
watch how the pronouns will change. Then
he may sift you as wheat. But I prayed
for thee. See the difference now? It
went from you to thee. T h e.
That thy faith fail not. When thou art
converted, strengthen thy brethren. Now
this is the beauty of the King James and
that it does something for you other
modern versions don't do. It will let
you know when the pronoun you is one or
two or more. And how do you know that?
Whenever you see in the King James these
words thee, thy, thine, thou, that's
one. But when it's you, your, ye, that's
two or more. Did you understand the
feature there?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, did you catch what Jesus said?
Simon has asked for you,
but I prayed for thee.
You catch it?
>> Mhm. So Jesus again singled out Peter. I
prayed for thee when thou are restored,
right? Converted. Go and strengthen thy
brethren. So notice the three privileges
or three facts, three blessings. He
speaks to Simon individually, not to the
rest, not to all. And he says to Simon,
I prayed specifically for you. And then
he trusts Simon with the responsibility
of restoring the rest after Satan has
sifted them. So if you look at the
Bible, you'll see this pattern of Peter
being singled out for privileges and a
status. Not that he deserved it because
he's no better than the rest because of
God's grace. Another example, if you
don't mind, you can use the New King
James for this one. Go to Mark 16, read
verses 6 to8. Mark 16 6 to8 and pay
attention to verse 7.
>> But he said to them, "Do not be alarmed.
You seek Jesus of Nazareth who was
crucified. He is risen. He is not here.
See the place where they laid him. But
go tell his disciples and Peter.
>> You see Peter singled out again. Huh?
>> Yeah.
>> Why single out Peter when this is
mentioning disciples includes him
automatically?
Go tell disciples and Peter again Peter
is being singled out. Now keep reading.
and Peter that he is going before you
into Galilee. There you will see him as
he said to you.
>> Okay, so you got it. And then what
happened? What what happens in verse
eight? What do they do?
>> So they went out quickly and fled from
the tomb for they trembled and were
amazed and they said nothing to anyone
for they were afraid.
>> Now go to Luke 24. Luke 24. When you get
there, read from
read from I want to see where you should
start. Yeah. Start from 28 and read all
the way to 35. 28-35.
Luke 24:28-35.
>> Then they drew near to the village where
they were going. And he indicated that
he would have gone further, but they
constrained him, saying, "Abide with us,
for it is toward evening, and the day is
far spent." and he went in to stay with
them.
Now it came to pass as he sat at the
table with them that he took bread,
blessed, and broke it and gave it to
them. Then their eyes were opened and
they knew and they knew him and he
vanished from their sight. And they said
to one another, "Did not our heart burn
within us while he talked with us on the
road and while he opened the scriptures
to us?" So they rose up that very hour
and returned to Jerusalem and found the
11 and those who were with them gathered
together saying, "The Lord is risen
indeed and has appeared to Simon."
>> To who?
>> And Simon.
>> So again, he singles out Simon for
resurrection appearance.
>> Okay.
>> So notice what the Lord is doing for
Simon. He appears to Simon after the
resurrection one-on-one.
He singles out Simon for privileges such
as being the one once he's restored due
to Jesus's prayer that he'll go and
strengthen and restore the other
disciples. When the angels tell the
woman to go announce to Jesus's
followers that Christ is risen, they go
go to the disciples and Peter. And then
in the mount of transfiguration, Peter
is there. Gyrus's daughter being raised,
Peter is there. Garden of Gethsemane,
Peter is there. And on and on it goes.
This is not a coincidence. This repeated
pattern is deliberately designed by the
spirit in order to show that though
they're all one,
Peter has a position of primacy over the
rest. This is why even in Galatians 2:es
1-10, Galatians 2:es 1-10, if you read
that entire section, Paul says due to a
vision, obviously vision from Christ, he
was told to go back to Jerusalem 14
years after his ministry, 14 years later
after he converted to check within with
those reputed pillars of the church in
Jerusalem. And he mentions who those
pillars were, Simon, Peter, Cphas, John,
and James, the so-called brother of the
Lord. So this is a pattern that's there,
right? So there's no problem with Peter
being the rock, but no one believes he's
the rock alone. He is the rock and he
has a position of primacy over the rest.
But they too in union with Peter are the
foundation upon which Jesus built his
church.
Now if you go to let me give you one
more example how important the apostles
are including Peter. Go to Revelation
21, last book of the Bible. Read verses
9 to 14.
>> Then one of one of the seven angels who
had the seven bowls filled with the
seven last plagues came to me and talked
with me, saying, "Come, I will show you
the bride, the lamb's wife." And he
carried me away in the spirit to a great
and high mountain, and showed me the
great city, the holy Jerusalem,
descending out of heaven from God,
having the glory of God. Her light was
like a most precious stone, like a
jasper stone, clear as crystal. Also,
she had a great and high wall with 12
gates and 12 angels at the gates. And
names were written on them, which are
the names of the 12 tribes of the
children of Israel. Three gates on the
east, three on the north, three on the
south, and three on the west.
Now, the wall of the city had 12
foundations, and on them were the names
of the 12 disciples of the man. 12
disciples. Who says apostles?
>> Yes.
>> I thought you said disciples. So, you
see how important the apostles are,
including Peter. They're not only the
foundation of the church, they're the
foundation of heavenly Jerusalem, the
city that we will dwell in when it comes
down to the earth.
>> Okay.
So, I hope that clarified it. If you
have other questions, feel free.
>> Let me ask question.
>> Say again. Um,
so look, why is there such a controversy
between Catholics and Protestants about
this verse about Peter? If it's if it's
consistent throughout scripture,
>> that the apostles are
the of course they're important. They're
the foundation.
>> They are. Yeah.
Why is this such a controversial
controversial issue between Catholics
and Protestants? What what's the big
deal?
>> Well, here's the thing. When you say
Protestants, you're generalizing because
if you get Protestant commentators,
commentaries on the Gospel of Matthew by
Protestant scholars like Donald Carson,
most of them admit Peter is the rock
mentioned in Matthew 16. And I'll give
you just one name, Donald A. Carson.
He's an evangelical professor. He's not
Catholic. If you read his commentary,
he'll tell you that when Jesus said,
"Upon this rock, I build my church."
That's Peter. So, not all Protestants
deny that Peter is the rock of Matthew
16:1 18. Now, why do other Protestants
deny it? Out of reaction to the Catholic
Church. It's reactionary. They're afraid
to admit that if it's Peter, then that
means not only is Peter the head of the
church, and you know, it's the apostles
who are obviously they're the
foundation, but he's their head. then
that means Peter's successor would be
the head of the church on the earth. And
if the pope is Peter's successor, that
means he's the head of the church. And
they don't want to believe that and go
that far and accept it. But what I'm
telling you is here's here what I want
you to hear.
Even if you don't believe the pope is
the head of the church, that doesn't
mean that if you believe Peter is the
head that you have to believe the pope
is. In other words, believe it or not,
there are even people here who are
Orthodox, Coptic, Assyrian Church of the
East. I'm not saying they're right. So,
don't get me wrong. I'm not saying
they're right. What I'm trying to tell
you is you have Assyrian Church of the
East, Coptic Church, Orthodox, who all
accept Peter is the rock, the head of
the apostles, but they don't believe the
Pope alone is the head of the church.
They believe that all the bishops in
their respective seas are sitting on the
throne of Peter and have equal authority
over the church on earth. So what I'm
saying, you can believe Peter's rock and
still not accept that the pope is the
one head of the church, but it doesn't
mean you're right or wrong. This is a
debate even among Catholics, Orthodox,
Coptic, and Assyrian Church of East. And
I'm not here to solve that because I
don't have much knowledge about church
history to solve that issue.
>> Okay. So
does it matter? Does it matter which
interpretation you take?
>> Why is it so significant to the to why
is it so significant?
>> Well, it matters one way. We all want to
know God's interpretation of the Bible,
right? True. Yes.
>> So, it matters because we want to know
what God means. That's the first reason.
That's number one. Number two, it also
matters how you interpret the Bible
because depending on what passage you
interpret, you can come with wrong
theology that'll damn you to hell. For
example, does it matter how Jehovah's
Witnesses interpret those passages about
the Trinity?
>> Yeah.
>> Why? Why should it matter?
>> Because that's the nature of God. And we
need to understand
>> who God is, how he's revealed himself to
us.
>> So you see, so yes, interpretation can
matter and often does matter depending
on what you're interpreting.
That's the point.
>> So this particular thing, what is this?
>> Well, that's important, too, because
>> why is it so divisive?
>> Because it's talking about the most
important living organism on earth, the
church of Jesus Christ. There's nothing
more important to Jesus than a spiritual
body. the spiritual body on earth and in
heaven. So it does matter in that it's
not just talking about something that's
secondary. The church of Jesus is not
secondary.
>> The church of Jesus is essential because
it's a spiritual body on earth as well
as in heaven because you also have
church in heaven. But here in
particular, I'm talking about the church
on earth that the apostles went about
establishing. And what's more beloved to
Jesus than his bride? What's more
beloved to Jesus than his spiritual
body, the church? nothing.
So it is important in that area to get
it right. And you also have to check
when I say check yourself, not you. I
when I say you, I usually mean it
generally. You also have to check
yourself to see are you opposing Peter
being the rock out of reaction to
Catholicism? Because many Protestants do
that. I used to do that. I'm being
honest. I'm gonna speak of myself.
>> You're not doing that.
>> Good. That's all right. That's fine. But
I'm saying I used to do that.
>> I be on the side of truth. That's that's
what I want.
>> Amen. But I'm letting you know. I did
not want to accept Peter as the rock out
of reaction to Catholicism. I'm being
honest. See, I'm not going to lie. I
despise the Catholic Church because I
believe I'm telling you what I used to
believe 20 years ago. And I'm laughing
at myself, but thank the Lord he had
more on me and patience with me. I
believed it was the Antichrist system.
The Pope is the Antichrist. And there
were Jesuits who were working with the
Illuminati to bring about a one world
government. And you know, I was into all
of that.
>> It's funny now, but back then it was
serious.
>> Okay.